hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outboard and mha is
absolutely insane right now the entire
Todoroki family may have just been wiped
out in what is perhaps the greatest
tragedy in the entire series I don't
know what exactly horikoshi is cooking
right now but he's definitely turning up
the heat well past the boiling point
like literally people are on fire so
let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy our mha videos you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like right now for that YouTube
algorithm and if you're one of the over
50 of people who watch our videos but
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
I want to take this opportunity to ask
you to please subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications quick reminder about my
very favorite video that I've ever made
here on the channel it's a video in
which I talked about how Deku could have
become the main villain of the mha
series be sure to check that out Link in
the description and in the pinned
comment finally this video will contain
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned the
previous chapter gave us some massive
twist as it was revealed that Dobby has
a hidden ice Quirk which was finally
awakened during his epic battle against
his father Endeavor we had hints that
this might happen earlier on especially
with the fact that Dobby was able to
copy shoto's phosphor but the last
chapter confirmed Dobby's true ice fire
quirk in an absolutely epic fashion at
the very end of the chapter the fiery
fight between Father and Son was
interrupted by Dobby's mother Rey she
arrived on the battlefield and attempted
to use her powerful ice Quirk to cool
Dobby off and prevent him from dying by
blowing himself up but by doing so Rey
put herself in Mortal danger not only is
Dobby's father Endeavor in imminent
danger of dying at Dobby's hands but now
Rey Dobby's mother is also in that same
danger the latest chapter starts off
with a brief flashback bag that shows us
how exactly Ray arrived at the
battlefield from the UA shelter we see
that back at the shelter the heroes are
dealing with all for one spies we knew
about two of these spies from before but
it looks like there's actually more we
see that itsuka Kendo is restraining two
of them with her giant hand and tetsu
tetsu is restraining another one on the
ground combined with the guy who looks
like an adult mob from Mob psycho 100
that makes at least four spies not
counting the aoyamas of course this
doesn't even surprise me and in the past
I warned of the possibility that there
could be more spies inside the UA
shelter all for one has backup plans for
his backup plans so the fact that he
enlisted four or even more spies instead
of just one or two makes perfect sense
he made it so that even if a few of them
got caught such as the ayamas did there
would still be plenty of other agents
ready to do his bidding but even though
the heroes seem to be doing a good job
of restraining the spies right now the
damage has already been done the very
foundations of the shelters and its
security system have been compromised
and the civilians have no other choice
but to evacuate up to the surface the
heroes make sure that the civilians all
get out of the shelters with a special
emphasis on getting the children an
elderly out first then they tell the
civilians to ask the UA robots to take
them away from the danger zone these
robots have been programmed to follow
the instructions of the humans who ride
on top of them once everyone is up on
the surface they are told not to look in
the direction of Dobby and to just flee
in the opposite direction as fast as
possible that is because the place where
dabian Endeavor are fighting looks like
a freaking nuclear bomb just went off it
is a massive Inferno that reaches up to
the sky and that seems to swallow the
entire Horizon after seeing that most
people don't need any more convincing to
run away in the opposite direction
immediately however when Rey Todoroki
sees The Inferno she can't run away she
climbs on top of one of the robots and
this one has wheels and looks like a
futuristic AI ATV or something Rey tells
Natsu to take care of his sister and
then she asks the robot to take her to
the center of the Inferno back in the
present the robot ATV disintegrates from
the heat as Rey screams out her son's
name Toya she's using her extremely
strong ice Quirk to protect herself from
the flames and heat while also trying to
cool Dobby's body off so that he doesn't
explode but it's clear right away that
Rey's body is already burning and taking
serious damage even with her ice Quirk
working overtime as strong as her Quirk
is and we know that the himura family
has like the strongest ice quirks in
existence it still cannot negate the
effects of so much heat and Flame
Endeavor tells Rey that it's hopeless
she won't be able to cool Dobby off so
she has to get away from here as soon as
possible if she doesn't she'll just burn
to death along with him and Dobby but
Rey refuses to leave she calls out to
her son Toya and she says that she is so
sorry Dobby recognizes her and he begins
saying mom mom but then he also says
natsukun and fuyumichan Rey turns around
and sees that her two other children
Natsu and fuyumi are also heading
towards them and they are both using
their ice quirks to negate the effects
of Dobby's heat as much as possible Rey
screams at them to get away and we can
see that her skin is really starting to
disintegrate now she is taking serious
damage just from standing somewhat close
to Dobby and Endeavor and yet the
children refuse to listen they say that
they can't stand to have her leave them
again and they both call out to their
big brother and scream at him to please
not take their mom away they don't want
to lose anyone else they don't want
their family to suffer anymore Endeavor
then tries to speak to Dobby directly
and he begs his son to make him the only
one he kills he begs him not to kill Rey
Natsu and fumi along with him but
there's a big problem with endeavor's
request Dobby was never exactly sane but
right now he seems to be completely out
of his mind he doesn't seem to really
know what's actually going on around him
and we don't know whether he's even in
control of his own actions or whether
he's just gone completely berserk the
Flaming monstrosity that Dobby has
become appears to smile as he looks at
Endeavor and then the final page of the
chapter is quite a surprise we see an
image of the whole todroki family aside
from Shoto reunited and looking happy
they all look normal just wearing their
normal clothes and without any fire and
heat searing their skin even Dobby looks
like Toya again without any of his scars
or Burns and he's smiling at his father
as his father smiles back at him and as
Rey and the siblings look on lovingly
this page is a death flag if I've ever
seen one the text on the final page
reads reunited with his mother and
siblings what lies Beyond his gaze and
that is how the chapter ends I have to
admit the final page took me by surprise
the insane contrast between all of them
looking normal and happy versus what's
really going on in real time really got
me and I personally liked this touch I
thought it was symbolic and poetic in a
beautiful and painful way but this also
has me wondering are we about to witness
the death of the entire Todoroki family
Endeavor and W are both already severely
injured and on the verge of death
nowaday's skin is beginning to
disintegrate and Natsu and fumi could
suffer the same fate very soon I really
doubt that Dobby will just come back to
his senses is suddenly and lower his
temperature I don't even know if he can
do it anymore because it's probably gone
so far that it's out of his control
seriously are we about to see the tragic
end of the todorokis are some of them
going to die right here and now or maybe
even all of them we know that troto is
on his way but will he make it in time
and even if he does is there anything
that he can do to stop Dobby's flaming
Supernova from consuming his entire
family what an intense and suspenseful
way to end this chapter and what a
potentially heartbreaking twist
horikoshi has just set up for us this is
wild imagine what Shoto must be going
through right now when he arrives at the
goonga battlefield he will find his
entire family either already dead or in
immediate danger of perishing right
before his eyes can Shoto change the
tragic path that the todorokis seem to
be on right now and if so how what can
he even do will he Anita try to take
Dobby as far away as possible before he
explodes will Dobby actually come to his
senses and spare his family will
endeavor make the ultimate sacrifice to
save the others by giving up his own
life man I I don't know but this is
intense I have to give it to horikoshi
only a few chapters ago I wasn't even
thinking about Dobby versus Endeavor and
I was more interested in all might's
return than all for One's next move and
of course the battle between Deku and
full power shigaraki but now the Dobby
fight and the life or death predicament
of the Todoroki family is definitely the
most intense and suspenseful plot point
for me right now alright guys place your
bets down in the comments who lives and
who dies out of the Todoroki Clan could
all of them die or could all of them
somehow survive where is horikoshi going
with this let me know down below now if
you thought that this mha video was
intense don't ignore my video on how
Deku could have become the main villain
of the entire series Link in the
description and on screen if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more in
the future leave a quick like right now
for that YouTube algorithm and if you're
one of the over 50 of people who watch
our videos regularly but haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a big
favor and make this video video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications